the jurogan experience you know
oftentimes in in the ufc you'll see guys
when they go up and wait they become
their best version like charlo charles
oliveira is a great example of that like
he fought for 145 at a while for a while
rather and he fought very well but he
never really hit the strides that he hit
when he went up to uh 155. he's on a
roll now oh my god he's so good it's on
a roll he's so good and he's he
you know people take different
approaches they talk smack give fights
you know there's a whole different ways
to do it he's so respectful
and so nice yes and it's like
i mean whatever i guess it's different
for everybody but man he's got something
that's working right now and he's hard
not to root for yeah well that's who he
is he's a very very nice guy
and uh he got screwed in his last fight
they there was uh some shenanigans with
the scale
uh some people had messed with the scale
here's a problem with these digital
scales um foreign fighters uh they use
kilograms and in america obviously we
use pounds right and so the foreign
fighters were like these scales are
calibrated and then the foreign fighters
would reset the scale so they could
switch it back to kilograms so it [ __ ]
up the whole calibration
and so
he would weigh in or he weighed in like
the night before the weigh-ins he was
like oh i'm good to go and then in the
morning he goes and shows up for the
weight cut and it's a pound plus off and
that is directly
related to this calibration thing
calibration issue yeah
now they have a the ufc has a new policy
because of this where they have a guard
who watches over the scale 24 hours a
day like they have shifts where no one
can [ __ ] with the scale like if you're
gonna get on that scale to try yourself
they're gonna watch you like a hawk and
you don't press any buttons you don't
just get on what's your weight get off
that's it so these guys were monkeying
around with the scale and that's
surprising that even at the level that
ufc's at right now it's that was still
still hadn't got that figured out it's
phoenix yeah that's what it is and it's
not not not on knock on phoenix i love
phoenix it's just that the people that
are there don't do high-level world
championship mma fights on a regular
basis they do a few you know we've had a
good good time there they've had some
good events there but uh they just made
a mistake they'll let these guys do it
and there should have been someone
watching the scale and the scale was off
and that's a fact and that's why
oliveira look it's not the best excuse
because justin gaichi made weight yeah
everybody else made weight except uh one
of the the women that fought earlier in
the night she didn't make weight but
that's it
but how so i actually i wanted to gait
you in that fight i'm i'm a justin
gayche fan i love all this team i like
his
attitude i like he's a just a
so tough
um
but how impressive is it that oliveira
can have that all that drama which you
know how you got to be in the right
mindset to fight i imagine and he's got
to overcome all this and still then he
gets rocked yeah gets rocked twice by
gaichi who's got you know hands of stone
and still comes back and wins well
here's what's interesting about charles
oliveira when charles oliveira fights
even though he's the champion
he fights
like
like a berserker he fights he puts
himself in danger like he doesn't fight
safe he doesn't fight to try to out
point you he doesn't fight tactically
like where he's trying to get you know
the the least amount of damage and you
know and drag you into deep water and
then and then strategically try to take
you out the fourth and fifth round no
from the moment the first bell rings
he's coming at you engaging guns blazing
and gaichi was coming at him too but
it's like geichi was overwhelmed by
oliveira's pace and his aggression it's
why even when gaiji cracked him oliveira
is so different than anybody else when
he gets hit he just lays on his back
yeah and he's like come get some of this
and nobody wants that guard it's a break
he's got the most submissions in the
history of the sport he recovers yes so
he's cause nobody wants to go to the
ground right normally guys would just
come bombing in yeah just trying to land
anything extra it's like when you wound
an animal
any other arrow in it is right you're
just trying to glance something off
catches something
most time guys will hurt a guy come in
and just go crazy but not with him no
you don't want that ground game his
ground game is so elite it's so good i
mean i wonder how he would do in a like
world-class brazilian jiu jitsu
tournament because i think he would do
very well because i watch the way he
finishes submissions the way he syncs
things up i mean it is top of the food
chain stuff i've seen a lot of jiu jitsu
in my days i've rarely seen anyone
compete in mma that closes the show like
oliveira when the fight goes to the
ground his [ __ ] is razor sharp razor
sharp